what is spin it's something that
apparently some particles have that you
can measure but what is it in this video
I'll explain how we know spin exists but
also why we don't understand it spin was
a late comer to the quantum mechanics
party
even after Schrodinger wrote his famous
equation and everything seemed to be
working people didn't realize it existed
then people realize that some particles
seem to have odd magnetic properties the
original quantum mechanics didn't
predict and the source of that was
labeled spin to understand this we're
going to need one piece of classical
electromagnetism theory whenever a
charged particle moves it creates a
magnetic field this is pretty amazing
and you can see it for yourself by
putting the compass next to a charge
carrying wire in fact if you have a
charged particle going in a small loop
this not only creates a magnetic field
that field pretty much looks like it's
from a bar magnet so then we expect
charged particles moving around in
circles to act as little magnets since
that's something we know from classical
physics it was built into quantum
mechanics too from the start but
eventually some experiments showed that
there must be some other source of
magnetism I'm going to explain one of
those a simplified version of the
stern-gerlach experiment let's say we
have a bunch of electrons by themselves
they are charged but they're not doing
little loops so they shouldn't be
magnets we test this out by putting them
in a stern-gerlach apparatus I'm not
going to explain how the machine works
but what it does is this if a small
magnet is placed inside it measures its
orientation if the magnets North Pole is
up it exerts an upward force on the
magnet if the magnet is the other way
around it exerts a downward force of
course there are other orientations if
the magnet is like this the magnet is
still somewhat pointing up so the force
is still up but smaller it's
proportional to how much this magnet is
pointing in the up direction similarly
for this magnet pointing
down say a magnet is on its side then it
has no force at all but these are the
only ways the magnet can be oriented
either it could be forward or backward
or left or right or any combination and
so what happens there
well this machine only measures how much
the magnet is up or down if the magnet
is like this it's still pointing a bit
upward on the other hand if the magnet
was just pointing left or right or
forward or backward it wouldn't feel any
force and so it would go straight so
what we expect is if we shot through a
bunch of magnets in random orientations
they all land between here and here and
in a pretty smooth distribution of
course if we threw in a non magnet it
wouldn't feel anything and just go
through so that's what we should expect
with electrons but we do the experiment
and find something really odd the
electrons do experience forces as if
they're magnets but they don't spread
out smoothly either half of them go up
to the same height and the other half go
down again to the same height let's look
at this second mystery first if
electrons really are magnets we expect
them to be randomly oriented but these
results would be like saying that for
some reason half of them were pointing
exactly up and the other half exactly
down well maybe we did something very
wrong when we prepared them that meant
this happened so to test that let's do
something clever
let's turn the stern-gerlach machine on
its side what that does is now the
machine is measuring how much a magnet
is pointing to the left or right instead
of up or down the more the magnet is
pointing to the left the more left it
goes if a magnet isn't pointing either
left or right it just goes through now
let's use the same source of electrons
we had before we think that they're all
pointing up or down and so they should
just go through this machine and they
shouldn't be deflected at all what
happens half of them go right and half
of them go left so then they were
actually are
entered left and right all along but
that can't be right either let me
explain how to think of this in the
framework we built up in the last couple
of videos I can measure the up or down
nosov a particle so that is an
observable what are its eigenstates well
this experiment showed that the particle
can only be fully up or fully down and
nothing in between so they are the only
two eigenstates will call them spin up
and spin down now we can apply the
quantum mechanical principle that to
fully describe the wavefunction of this
particle we only need to describe it in
one basis so I can fully write the state
of this particle in terms of up and down
this is weird
because in classical physics it wouldn't
be enough to tell you the state of the
magnet I can't just tell you how much
it's pointing up or down I need to also
tell you how left or right it is and how
forward or backward but in quantum
mechanics this is enough let's see what
happens when we do some arbitrary
combination here since the square of
this number is bigger it has a bigger
chance of being spin down but it can
still be spin up it doesn't go 3/4 of
the way down ever though it's only ever
up or down but what about if I flip the
machine on its side to measure the left
rightness in quantum mechanics if you
tell me the wavefunction in terms of up
and down I should be able to figure out
what the wave function is in terms of
left and right to be able to do that we
just need to know how to convert up and
down to left and right but how the
coefficients should be equal in size if
we use this classical analogy a particle
that's fully up can't be pointing either
left or right at all a quantum particle
that's up but is being measured for left
or right nurse must go one way or the
other but at least it shouldn't be
biased towards one side now we need to
decide the sign of each of these if we
agree to call this right and that left
then it turns out that the right way to
do it is this and this is something
you'll recognize from the last two
videos okay
so now I've shown you how quantum
mechanics deals with spin let's return
to the much more difficult question what
is spin the electrons aren't doing
little loops so why are they magnetic
this was what was originally proposed
the electrons are spinning on their own
axis the idea is if you have a charged
ball that spinning that means bits of
charge are moving in a circle and so it
creates a magnetic field like a bar
magnet but we know this is wrong if this
was really true we can calculate how
large the electron should be it's bigger
than the whole atom it also makes some
other incorrect conclusions these days
we think the electron isn't a ball it's
an infinitely small point and that can't
spin I think this image of an electron
spinning is really more harmful than
helpful not just because it makes all
kinds of incorrect predictions but
because feeling like we understand
something stops us from asking what it
is but making this video I realize that
there are lots of other physics terms
that I don't understand what is energy
what's charge it seems like we define
these things by how we measure them and
then the same is true for spin spin is
the thing that makes particles act a bit
like magnets I really hope that in the
future as we understand more physics
more of these terms can be understood in
terms of deeper physics at least there's
some hope for spin I told you that spin
had to be added into quantum mechanics
in an ad hoc way this is true but when
Dirac tried to merge standard quantum
mechanics and relativity something in
his new equation acted a lot like spin
while this was awesome I don't feel like
it solves the mystery of spin because
while it comes out in the mats it still
doesn't explain what it is or why
relativity demands it exists but maybe
there are some properties of physics
that we can never understand and maybe
spin is one of them there was so much
more I could have said about spin but I
ran way over time so I thought it would
be fun if you guys taught each other
instead in the description I put a whole
lot of questions I didn't answer in this
video I would love if you picked one or
more
of these or found your own and did some
research you can present your work in
any format you want as a youtube comment
on any of these social media accounts or
on your own website etc and it would be
kind of amazing if you want to make it
into a video but I know that's a bit
daunting as for the content you should
know that some of the questions I asked
in the description are ones that I don't
know the answer to despite trying to
find out so it's absolutely fine to just
make an attempt this doesn't have to be
a huge thing also a lot of sources claim
to answer these questions but leave big
gaps or make potentially unjustified
assumptions and some of these questions
are still unanswered even though there
are some interesting leads so then your
task isn't necessarily to definitively
answer your question in fact I'd way
rather you point out why you don't
understand something or discuss several
possible solutions don't worry about
being dumb not knowing things isn't dumb
but pretending you do is I'd love if you
read each other's responses if you want
to give any constructive feedback and
start a discussion then awesome I
encourage that so much but just remember
to be kind anyway good luck and I'm
really looking forward to learning
things from you